hello everyone welcome to rational
science
the only site on the internet that does
physics right everybody else does math
and irrational explanations
uh what's an irrational explanation well
primarily when you move concepts around
you know they move fields they move
energy they move mass
can you imagine moving mass
i mean i can move the elephant but can
you move the mass of the elephant
that's the issue
and so uh yeah we're the only site that
does that usually we do extinction at
the beginning
but uh there's not much uh subject
matter there this week at least uh
there's still no war in ukraine okay and
uh so everybody's just moving their
pawns around and waiting to see what
happens and then we have covid and uh
not much going on there i guess uh the
only news i can give you is here in
frankfurt on the 1st of march
they're going to shut down the covid
testing facility at the at the airport
so um i guess that's dying down as well
it seems like it at least you know
so not much going on in in those fields
another subject matter here is uh the
moon we have the moonies and the flat
earthers
but we have moonies which are people who
don't believe that we went to the moon
and there are then uh i guess you can
call them lunatics so that we don't
confuse them uh with the moonies and the
lunatics some of them are moonies right
and those lunatics they believe that the
moon spins
can you believe that they think the moon
spins
okay so i'm gonna address that because
there were several issues brought up
uh on that subject and i want to make
sure that these people know what the
arguments are on both sides so let's
start with the uh what these people are
saying what these people are questioning
or how they reason if you can call it
reasoning
okay so here let's go first guy he says
the earth is rotating
with the moon orbiting earth okay
contradicts himself meaning me right by
saying the moon doesn't rotate
the moon uh has to rotate on its axis to
keep one side facing the earth okay and
a lot of people think like this okay so
uh
it's not just this fellow but a lot of
people are thinking along these lines
they say the moon has to spin if it goes
around the earth right yeah it's
sometime in it's gone one time around
its axis in other words right
the moon's rate of rotation matches its
orbital period which keeps the same side
facing them the earth okay
okay
that's one fella here's here's another
fella and he says
says uh we are talking about spin
relative to the sun
heliocentrism
so he's saying the moon spins because it
moves with respect to the sun okay
and again he's not the only fellow who
says that here's another fella who says
more or less the same thing okay
and so he says when you point to a large
x on the moon's equator this mark will
experience
a 354 hour lasting night and a 354 hour
lasting day so yes the moon is spinning
in relation to the sun and the other
stars okay
so this is a common argument by the way
okay a lot of people think that the moon
is spinning with respect to earth the
moon is spinning with respect to the sun
this moon is spinning with respect to
all the stars in the universe that's the
notion okay
uh another foul says
stuck a rod through the moon having it
move with the moon one side of the rod
always facing a mountain yeah i'm saying
that you know if you put a rod right
through the earth or the moon right
in the case of the moon
if you color code that rod right maybe
put
uh red on one side half of it red half
of it uh blue
imagine a cylinder that's more or less
depicted there
okay and uh if the moon spins in other
words uh or or how the moon moves right
if you have a mountain facing the red
part of that cylinder
it will always face that red part of the
cylinder it'll move together with the
red part it's not like the rod stand
stationary and the moon moves with
respect to the red part of the cylinder
that's the argument okay so let's
understand what the issue is in this his
claim is that the moon doesn't rotate
okay yeah exactly okay so that's going
to be my argument and all these lunatics
is like
they believe the moon spins okay let's
let's get to the bottom of this okay
today okay
and here we have another fella what why
would the red poke true uh rod poke
through the moon be any different from a
rod poke through the earth okay so this
is the issue okay he's saying if we put
a rod through the moon through the earth
they're the same that's a saying why is
there any difference here he doesn't see
that okay with respect to what are you
uh holding the rod stationary okay
and uh so in other words you know i mean
is there anything that's stationary in
the entire universe essentially that's
what he's saying okay so he's saying
it's uh i guess it's a
misconceived
scenario okay because the rod you cannot
hold it stationary with respect to
anything
maybe with respect to god and the angels
heaven you know but not with respect to
anything else in the universe
a uh top-down view of the earth and moon
alone regardless of which one uh the
view is centered on make it plainly
obvious that both are rotating
okay okay
so we have all these arguments okay keep
i i hope you're you're keeping track of
them these are all the lunatics
okay another fella says um standing
facing uh north i will begin at your
left and facing you i am facing uh east
okay
i will go around in front of you
continually facing you at your right
side i am now facing west having done
half a rotation so he went from east to
west right
i will continue around behind you
to your left side i'm facing east again
okay so he went all the way around okay
and i have done one full rotation on my
own axis
and
that there are people who can't
understand that is a
freaking despairing embarrassment to
humanity
and uh
continues here
he says uh after his brutal peer review
in the comments uh will grifter
guillermo understand that his observed
observation of the moon and not rotating
is ludicrously
bogus
okay so we have these strong opinions
these strong arguments from all these
folks okay
okay uh
let's see if we can answer some of these
folks
i think there's one more
is it
no
okay so here here's the deal for you
okay
i i want you to tell me okay
uh this is a test we're gonna do an
experiment we're gonna do
mathematical physics here we're gonna do
observation okay
okay so here it is i'm gonna put
something in front of you i want you to
tell me if it's
okay that's that's the million dollar
question okay you're gonna look at
something i want you to tell me if it is
spinning okay here it is
okay here's the moon
is it spinning
okay
and uh we're gonna assume for the sake
of argument that it's the only object in
the universe
okay
we're gonna assume it's the only object
in the universe the question is is that
object that moon spinning that's the
question for you okay now you say well
obviously it's spinning right because i
can see it spinning you know
no need to say anything more
okay let's let let's do
let's follow up on this experiment i
want you to close your eyes now and tell
me if it's spinning
okay so i want you to close your eyes
and tell me if it's
we're
spinning
to remove the observer because i said
this is the only object in the universe
there are no observers there are no
reference points
is the moon spinning when you close your
eyes
okay
and let's continue with the experiment
here's a second part of that experiment
okay
is the moon spinning now
and you can open your eyes again by the
way
okay is the moon spinning
and you might say well no it's not
spinning it's like stationary
well maybe it's spinning but you're uh
going around in circles with it and so
you always see the same face
how can you tell if it's spinning or not
if you're always looking at the same
face
if you're moving at the same rate it is
it's moving around the circle
how do you know it's spinning
okay you're always staring at the same
face of this object there this
satellite that we have next to the earth
okay so these are the the questions
so how do we answer these questions in
science
well in religion in mathematical physics
and all these lunatics what they say
well i got a
i gotta touch
i gotta run and experiment i i gotta
check out the phenomenon to tell you
and that's not what the way we do it in
science
the way we do it in science is we define
the word spin
then if it meets the definition of the
word spin it spins
and if it doesn't meet the definition of
the word spin it don't spin it's just
that simple
we don't need the eyes we don't need the
hands
we don't need to observe we don't need
to have a second object okay
outside of the moon in this case right
to tell us whether the moon spins
and that's where the problem starts now
uh what's the big problem the big
problem is the last 10 000 years
not a single human being
on any part of our planet has ever
defined a word a single word
scientifically
okay we don't have scientific
definitions
especially of the key words that make or
break our arguments our theories that's
where the problem starts
okay
so let's look at this word spin let's
see if we can get to the bottom of spin
so that we're all on the same page
because right now we're not none of us
are on the same page
so here it is okay
here's spin okay and these are the
abbreviated versions that i got from
dictionaries okay
spin to turn around an axis
okay
synonyms include rotate gyrade circle to
circle right to twirl to whirl
the spiral you know that's what these
synonyms are what does rotate mean just
a couple here rotate to turn around an
axis or center point
okay what is gyrate to move in a circle
or spiral or around a fixed point
and what is the circle well to move in a
circle you know everybody knows i guess
what a circle is right i hope i don't
have to go that deep
or circuit around rotate or revolve
around
what's the problem well the problem are
the synonyms the synonyms are you know
you use words such as revolve orbit to
go around and those are usually synonyms
of spin all these words are used as
synonyms they're used interchangeably
that's great for poetry
it's terrible for science
we need to dif
know the difference between spam for
example in orbit
especially those two words
and so here you see revolve okay again
two of those words that are considered
synonyms right revolve to move in a
circular or curving course or orbit okay
and what is orbit to move in a curved
path the curved path around a body
okay so these are the notions that we
have of these words
and
the big problem here is that we mix them
up
and we considered an orbit the same
thing as spin that's where the problem
comes in because these words have never
been defined scientifically
okay so i'm gonna give it a my best shot
i'm gonna try to define them
scientifically for you what we mean so
that we can distinguish black from white
and don't confuse them okay
and so here we go
these are my definitions by the way spin
uh we're gonna talk about a 3d object
because you can have a 2d
object
conceptually talking about spin like you
know spinning of a circle or whatever
you can talk in those terms okay so i
just in case i separated them even
though
2d objects don't move but we can make a
move on the screen for example and
imitate
the the thought that we have in our
minds right
and so what's the issue spin 3d circular
motion of an object's surface around its
fixed fixed
axis
okay we're gonna see what that means
and what is the spiral well it's more or
less the same thing except that the
object does not maintain the same
distance back and forth okay motion of
an object's surface around its fixed
axis
while receding and approaching so the
thing wobbles so to speak right
what is an orbit
well it's a little different orb is not
spin
okay orbit circular or elliptical motion
of an object around another
so what are we talking about spin
is with respect to an imaginary center
of the same object
orbit is around another
object
orbit involves two distinct objects and
we're talking about this one going
around
another object which is in the center of
this circular
motion
on the other hand in the case of spin
we're talking about the surface of this
object
and it's rotating you know it's going
around
with respect to an imaginary axis that
runs right through the center of the
object
but what is the key issue the key issue
is fixed
that axis has to be fixed
in order for the thing to spin otherwise
it's not spinning
okay let's get a little deeper here so
we can visualize what i'm talking about
and here we have spin and spiral involve
a single object and its imaginary axis
of that object orbit on the other hand
involves two objects okay i hope we
understand at least the difference i'm
not asking you to agree
i'm trying to clarify to you the
difference between spin and orbit you
don't have to agree i just want you to
understand it okay so let's get that
straight also okay some people think i'm
shoving this down their throat no you
don't have to accept and i don't care if
you do or not science doesn't care if
you accept it or not science only cares
that we understand what the other guy is
saying so that he can he can present his
case
okay that's that's the point that i'm
trying to make here okay
okay
let's move on
and let's look at a couple cases here
here's the moon
versus the earth
okay
i want you to look at the axis
now i made the axis fat
you know it's not one dimensional
because there's no such thing as a
one-dimensional object uh i could have
made it two-dimensional just a
some kind of rod that goes through it
like a plane
half of it
color coded red the other one blue
instead i made it into a cylinder i hope
you won't hold that against me because
it turns out that this axis you know
runs through the earth and the moon both
of which are 3d objects okay so we're
going to put a an axis but we're going
to make the axis fatter so that i can
make my case so that you understand the
concept that's it not that you agree
with it i want you to understand okay
let's get all that straight okay so
here's the moon versus the earth okay
you can see uh the moon rotates together
with its axis
the earth does not rotate with its axis
if you stick a stick right through it
now that we're going to consider that
stick that i driven through it as a
fixed
stick it doesn't move it doesn't move
with respect to the planet in this case
right the earth on the right
in the case of the moon it does twirl
together with the moon we say that the
one on the left is correct not only is
correct but it's not spinning
it's not spinning because it's not
spinning with respect to you you're
saying well spinning with respect to me
you don't exist i'm asking you to close
your eyes i'm asking you to just follow
the definition of the word spin and if
it rotates together with its axis it's
not spinning by definition
okay i hope we get that straight on the
other hand and in the case of the earth
it is spinning because it's twirling
around with respect to a fixed axis
okay
and here we have the moon versus the
moon okay the two cases so that you can
compare side by side
the one on the left is correct the moon
is uh spinning together with the axis
meaning it's not spinning at all okay so
it's rotating with the axis if you were
moving together with the moon you were
moving all around the moon at that
moment in time you you would always see
the same face
okay which is the case today on the
other hand what it does not do what the
moon does not do is what you see on the
right where the axis is fixed and the
moon is changing the surface of the moon
is changing locations with respect to
the axis that's not what happens out
there
okay so these are the differences you
need to define words so that you can
communicate in science
and so
we have to define what spin really means
what orbit means and not confuse these
two concepts okay
of course people can ask questions later
on
and i'll look at them but i just wanted
you to get the notions here the notion
is that
the moon does not spin
with respect to its axis it's not
rotating with respect to its axis the
surface of the moon is not changing its
locations with respect to its axis the
axis is turning together with the moon
if we consider the axis as being a pole
run right through the center of the moon
okay right through the middle on the
other hand the earth does
rotate with respect to a fixed axis
we're going to call that spin we're
going to say the other one is not
spinning we don't spin with respect to
observers we don't speak spin with
respect to the sun we do not spin with
respect to the galaxies we spin with
respect to an axis
of the object you don't need to observe
you can close your eyes you just follow
the definition
and i promise
that
i won't hurt you
okay
i hope we get that straight
so if you don't want to be hurt uh
just follow the definition
okay move on to another subject uh or
more or less phil says uh i know i got i
got these two folks here you have uh
niels bohr and uh wolfgang pauley
and they were trying to figure out what
spinning is okay you you hear about
electron spin
and
it comes from all the way from the 1920s
they started talking about spinning of
electrons
and so the question is these two bozos
here they were trying to figure out
whether top spins okay
and yeah i guess if they looked at it
and they figured out oh if it's just
standing still then it's still spinning
why because it's pointed north and
that's more or less the notion that you
have of spin according to quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics has not
defined spin and they don't have any
idea what spin means or is or they they
have not visualized what spin is but
they talk about spin they insinuate that
it's spinning like
the moon is spinning you know standing
still with respect to the or moving with
respect to its axis right
in other words the axis is rotating so
is the surface of the moon and these
people have even a worse notion of what
spin is they said that
spin is orientation it's a static
concept
what do they mean they mean that when
they measure something it's pointed in a
given direction
they assign a number to that like half
or one or minus half
and they say well it's got a spin of
minus half
now i'm going to give you a top
i want you to spin it
and tell me if it's got a spin of minus
half or plus half or one or minus one or
whatever what sense does that make to
give a number to a spin
but that's what they have in quantum
that gives you a notion that something
is not completely
right or or in accordance what we
understand by spin
when when i tell someone spin everybody
thinking of a top you know you you spin
up top and say okay i know what that is
that's not what spin is in quantum
mechanics in fact it's never been
defined okay and here is a definition
of uh spin
electron spin
just so that you know what spin means or
is for the purposes of quantum mechanics
electron spin spin the total angular
momentum
of a rigid body or particle what is
momentum
well uh momentum is uh
you know that little p
in mathematics and so we're talking
about a number
that's what
momentum that's what spin is for the
purposes of quantum mechanics for for
mathematical physics okay so when they
talk about momentum and assign a number
what the hell does that have to do with
spin physical spin spinning atop
okay so that's where the issue is and so
you look it up it says the actual
angular momentum is a what
quantum number
multiplied blah blah blah blah blah okay
so it's a quantum number
and there they have values at multiples
of 12 and bosons have spin values that
are integer multiples of one and who
knows what else
so they're talking about numbers and
when you look they they they don't even
talk about numbers because they try to
give you an idea that they're talking
about something which is related to
physics and they say what do you really
mean by one and by minus half and all
these spins what these quantum numbers
and so they have to illustrate something
for you to you know sink your teeth into
and so what did they do they said well
one spin is north and the other one is
spinning south
so uh and they they put that little
arrow see that arrow is there uh
misleading because people say well i i
know what that is that's like a top and
the arrow's spinning this one the other
guy's spinning the other way no
absolutely not
that that arrow that curved arrow
that's there just to confuse you to
mislead you to send you on a tangent to
make you believe that they're talking
about spin no they're not talking about
spin that arrow is there by mistake or
deliberate who knows but the point is
spin is whether it's pointing north or
whether it's pointing south pointy
pointing meaning static concept we're
not talking about rotation here okay so
just keep that in mind the word spin is
very misleading in um
quantum mechanics
just like the word object the word thing
is misleading in all of mathematical
physics when they talk about like a
mathematical object what the hell's a
mathematical object what are we talking
about what is it number five is is that
a mathematical object there are no such
thing as mathematical objects not in
physics all we have is objects
and space
object and also concepts right
space nothing is also one of the
concepts that's it either it has shape
or it don't
period we're done it's black or white
and when you have it black or white
people understand but when you have all
this gray stuff in between and you lose
people that's where the problem is okay
uh another issue
paul says ah where did he go all the way
to the bottom to the other side give me
a second
uh one of these uh moonies comes up he
says vacuum space and non-rigid
protection gear uh also known as nasa's
spacesuits which are obviously flexible
and thus not rigid do not get along well
he's saying that
you can't really build a space suit that
is flexible and that can withstand the
the radiation
i hope i'm still online let me know
otherwise okay
sometimes i get involved with myself and
don't realize that people are not
following me anymore because i've been
cut off or whatever but it looks like
i'm still online
anyway it says reproducing a vacuum
space here on earth requires rigid walls
that's this fella's opinion says a human
in a vacuum chamber requires rigid
protection or else the vacuum will suck
his blood right out of his capillaries
deep sea divers also require rigid
shielding in submarines diving bells or
in their deep sea diving suits they make
uh of spare of spherical metal plates
like the one you showed in your previous
video bill
vacuum chambers and deep-sea diving
would not be possible if the shielding
barriers were made of stretchable
flexible aquaprene etc etc okay a lack
of rigid barriers means no chance of
surviving high pressure environments the
deep sea or our moons allege negative
surface pressure of 10 to the minus 8
really it's 10 to the minus 11 10 to the
minus 12. it's higher than what he put
there okay
and he says is this still and clear to
you yeah it is
the official narrative is so
preposterous nasa's spacesuits and
vacuum outer space are both
non-sequiturs
intellectual dead ends
okay so uh
he uh
vented his frustration there okay
and this is what i can tell you i'm
going to show you these are some of the
layers that a spacesuit has these are
how they build the spacesuits that the
astronauts
have to wear when they go to out into
space or to the moon it's got several
layers and it's got several protective
layers against radiation and also
against the vacuum
you know in other words the or the lack
of pressure you can say right vacuum
um and here's another picture of that
okay
and you can see they have all these
layers you can look them up on the
internet and find out all the layers
that all these spacesuits have
and to me
i have no problem
with understanding this but this file
says that this is impossible that all
these layers will not protect you
in outer space that means according to
him we will never be able to go into
outer space
humans right
because
we cannot build a spacesuit that's going
to protect us against vacuum and
radiation which are two of the
main points that people raise especially
flat earthers some of the moonies right
they raise these issues that we cannot
withstand that out there
and
i just want to clarify a couple things
that
people sometimes exaggerate i think it's
going to come up later in one of the
comments someone made and that's that
you know you look at the solar wind okay
just look at the solar wind and you have
a minus 12 minus 13 torr
okay
now that might not mean much to most
people out there but we're talking about
very very few particles per centimeter
cube or per meter cube depending on you
know what what
denominator you use there okay so
there's very few particles compared to
what you have here on earth
so when you have the astronaut go out
there he's not being bombarded by
particles like people say oh i'm going
to get into a shower and i'm going to be
showered with all these particles
hitting me
that's not the case
we have almost total vacuum compared to
what we have here on earth in other
words right
very few particles are coming and
striking these guys okay
you could have a particle
maybe a hydrogen atom i don't know maybe
a sodium atom just uh ion really uh it
could be anatomy yes in this case just
being flung out from the sun
and it just goes right through your suit
you're talking about an atom
one atom okay what is an atom well it's
an atom something you can't see
that's what an atom is that's how small
it is
we have atoms going through our bodies
uh even here on earth not not like every
second or maybe we do in a sense but
it's not like we're bombarded and we got
a shower of
high speed particles going through our
bodies okay
uh
some particles go through our bodies
some of them do damage maybe and maybe
that's why we get cancer maybe that's
why you know we we have uh we age or who
knows what
but point is that when you're out in
outer space you don't get uh protection
but at the same time you don't get
particles there are no particles in 10
to the minus 12 10 to the minus 13 torr
which is what the solar wind is
made of
you know solar wind is pure vacuum
i wish we could have
a solar wind level vacuum
in our chambers like you know when i
used to run uh
uh
silicon wafers boy if we could achieve
minus seven minus eight torr would be
great you know and and out there in the
solar wind you have minus minus 13.
a few particles
if if we could
if we could put a a a lab out there a
a fab area to produce chips
we could do it you know with in the
solar wind that's how
how uh lack of pressure you know you
have out there you have very little uh
pressure you have a lot of vacuum and
what that means you could build chips
out there that's how how little that's
how few particles would be penetrating
the chips and and screwing them up
i mean we use again
five to the
five times ten to the minus seven tors
what the typical vacuum level is in a
fabrication area and out there you get
minus 12.
so no you're not going to be
showered with bullets in other words it
could happen that some stone comes to
you and that's why they try to give the
astronauts as much protection as they
can
other than that they're not worried that
they're going to be bombarded with
particles every second and say oh look
at all those pebbles coming at us no
such monster we have almost pure vacuum
out there in in space
so all those people that
on the one hand raise radiation meaning
they think particles radiation are
particles in their mind and they say oh
all these particles are hitting them
that's on the one hand then they take
the particles out and they say oh but
now they're in vacuum
because see the radiation is the
opposite of particles in a sense either
you get hit by stones or there are no
stones and now you say well you can't
withstand the vacuum
okay which is it
are we hit by stones or or do we have
pure vacuum out there please tell me
yeah you can't have both arguments you
can't say on the one hand or we have
radiation which is a bunch of particles
you know photons and
maybe electrons right hitting you on the
one hand and then on the other side was
pure vacuum when we wouldn't be able to
withstand it
and so you know you got to make up your
mind you can't hold both arguments okay
okay they're contradictory they're uh
their opposite uh you know their
opposite arguments okay another foul
says can't live on the moon because of
the supplies and energy needed to
sustain a livable habitat
okay
at right at night the moon drops down to
two minus 243
degrees fahrenheit and during the day it
gets extremely hot 253 degrees
fahrenheit okay
and that's a huge temperature swing
between day and night
yeah but that's what these suits are uh
designed to protect against that's one
the other one is we're not talking about
the guy going out there and doing some
gardening you know we're talking about
the the fellow going out there first
in a capsule some kind of capsule he has
a place to go if he has some kind of
trouble that's one issue but the idea
for living on the moon
which is i think very possible is you
build a station there and you make it
you know like you would build a station
here on earth with all the little uh you
know things that you need you would need
the right pressure okay you would need a
little bit of air in there so that you
can breathe and and so on and so forth
so i think it could be done you can also
have nested
uh buildings so that one is nested
within the other so you have double
protection triple direction whatever
we could build something on the moon but
just think of what it would take to
build something on the moon
you would have to take all these parts
little by little you know piecemeal
okay
like an ant you know carrying your leaf
and we would have to take a lot of
leaves out there
to build that little station with all
the gadgets that we would need to live
you know comfortably you know like a
couch and television set and phone num
you know phone all that kind of stuff it
takes a long time to build something
like that so
you know my reply is yeah we we can live
on the moon we can safely live on the
moon i think we can have the um
um
what is it the the
uh people move out there you know maybe
10 guys and they live in this building
again could be a nested building but the
construction of that
first it takes a lot of money okay
that's one issue the other one is
why would we go to the moon what is
there on them is there gold on the moon
or what is it is the gold rush
the moon gold
what's going on on the moon that we need
to go to the moon we go there with
pick some rocks and bring them back to
earth
there's no reason for us to go to the
moon
now uh military could find a reason
maybe
i think it's too far away to do anything
here on
to any enemy here on earth that would be
one issue but let's assume we develop
some kind of technologies
that laser technology that you can zap
someone from the moon or something along
those lines
uh okay maybe there's a military
advantage
uh far-fetched military advantage to go
to the moon another one would be we
could mine the moon we could get maybe
uh uranium maybe we run out of uranium
here on earth or maybe lead or some
other
element and we say well we can mine it
on the moon and it's cheaper or maybe we
ran out of it here on earth and we can
get it on the moon those things should
happen but again
taking bulldozers and all that kind of
stuff to
to mine out there you know uh
or you know cranes and whatever
uh yeah
uh i i can imagine that you know how
many trips you would have to make each
trip costs a lot of money uh if you send
humans in every trip that's very
expensive because you know you never
know if you have an accident the guy
dies out there
so there's no reason really to go to the
moon i don't think we we will ever go to
the moon maybe we'll go to the moon
again maybe again to explore maybe to
sound out
you know or or put some kind of uh
thing that will help us construct the
station there
little by little so maybe they would put
something at the beginning uh study the
environment a little more get a little
experience on being on the moon
there will be a process
and i'm sure
the extension of man will occur on on
earth before we get our first station
out there
so
if we go to the moon we we go to the
moon one more time but it's just like
the neil armstrong buzz aldrin uh type
situation they walk on the moon they
jump around
rip
get some bra rocks and bring them to her
that's about it
there's no more than that
okay uh phil says
you have never seen the curvature of the
earth we have a flat earther
okay uh well
that's the flat earth and i i think i
see curvature there
so even under the flat earth
version
of the earth we have curvature
so yeah i'm sorry to tell you curvature
is curvature it's it exists under the
globe
uh earth and under the flat earth both
are
have curvature okay so yeah we i'm sorry
to tell you okay but um here's the globe
earth and some people believe in the
flat universe
and one of them is uh mr stephen hawking
who uh died a couple years ago
and this is what he
uh
posted i guess well this is what came
out in times magazine and they show this
flat uh board and it doesn't have
curvature it's kind of squarish so maybe
they're maybe he's right maybe under
this flat earth version because if the
universe is flat i guess the earth is
flat as well right uh maybe under this
version there is no curvature so that's
the only thing i can think of uh for
those
of you who want to kick the
issue around but yeah other than that
yeah we do have um
curvature whether you take the flat
earth version or the
uh real person the globular version but
all i can tell you is the following is
that um
you know uh
in in um
science
we don't have to see
curvature okay so he said have you ever
seen curvature i don't have to see
curvature
okay
i mean if i see it from if i'm outside
the the earth
and i see it from afar like from a
bird's eye perspective and i say okay
yeah
i can see the curvature it's obviously
curved but you know i'm not out there
i'm in here and so the question is do i
have to see the curvature of earth
and the answer is no
first we define the word curvature okay
we have to define the word so we're all
on the same page and then all i have to
do is imagine you know whether the earth
is flat as some of these people say or
whether the earth is spherical okay more
or less spherical
and
under my uh theory uh or actually my
assumptions um the earth has to have
better be curved uh globular you know
because
um
gravity works through all the atoms
being tugged towards the center of the
earth
and so yeah
just by thinking along by visualizing it
had better look like a ball okay uh if
you cannot explain gravity you cannot
claim that you have a flat earth uh
scenario okay you got to explain gravity
and no one in flat earth land has ever
explained gravity
some of them
use electricity like the
electric universe folks others um
talk about uh what is it density and uh
you know okay they have all kinds of
theories there are several theories for
the flat earth depending on which one
each flat earther adopts so you can't go
and attack them all but the issue is
that you know they have not explained
gravity and gravity is very simple to
explain all atoms are physically
interconnected and if they're all
physically
interconnected every celestial object
out there at least of a certain size
right a certain diameter certain certain
radius had better be
a spherical object okay
so yeah all objects out there are
spherical only the small ones maybe like
an asteroid something that exploded or
broke up then you got a different
situation but anything that is more or
less big out there had better be
uh circle and again the theory there is
that all those were
suns all those were stars okay
okay falsehoods air water and light
don't go don't curve another flat
earther you can
put a put up theories or explanation it
is all in vain
and i keep uh showing these people that
yeah we can explain the curvature of
water the curvature of air like you see
there and they never come back to even
listen to the theory because if they
came back and they said well bill you're
wrong about this or are irrational about
that you know i didn't understand this
or whatever they never come back they
just keep going from side to side just
saying oh you cannot explain the
curvature of air or the curvature of
earth of water and they keep going and
they never come back for an answer okay
so yeah here it is the answer i've put
it many times one more time won't hurt i
guess and there it is okay
every atom of air every atom of water of
the ocean
is tugged is connected physically
connected to every atom on earth
uh both solid and also to other atoms of
air and water
and so everything is gonna um
tug towards the center of the earth
we're done and that had better be a
spherical uh result from this okay
and so we're done i guess you know
that's all we need to know
all we need to do is understand
uh why the earth is spherical and yeah
we can curve water not in your bathtub
because if people say well when i look
at it in my bathtub it looks you know
like plain and i can't make it curve
well yeah i mean you know uh you're
looking at a very small um portion of
water now you want to see it curve you
got to go and put air around the earth
you got to put water around the earth
that's different and if every atom is
physically interconnected with all other
atoms and you can produce curved air and
curved water very very easily only uh
for babies uh this is kindergarten stuff
okay
okay and now the file says
for your information recent discovery of
a child's tooth in a french cave dates
back to 54 000 years ago i guess right
uh so much so much for your theory that
the neanderthals and humans could not
have mixed
these people believe everything they
read they don't even analyze it they
just say oh okay the scientists found
they discovered the paleontologists
no this is nonsense obviously it's
nonsense
and um so you look up this um uh
where he got this and here you find the
uh the article okay
uh at least one article analyzing that
did humans and neanderthals hang out
together okay
and uh they found a french cave they
found a tooth in there and the question
was whether this tooth belonged to a
human or to a neanderthal okay that was
the first issue a lot of people don't
agree with these uh with those people
who wrote this um
paper
and you can see it here it says uh the
research don't have any hard evidence of
interaction between the two groups
meaning neanderthals and cro-magnets
okay
then it says the tools found in the
layers representing the homo sapiens and
neanderthal occupations are distinct in
style and don't show any sign that they
taught one another
uh napping or flaking stonework
techniques in other words they had
babies but but they didn't learn the
other guy's technique for making tools
and weapons that's interesting right
it's like oh no i just came here to
screw your wife you know
direct contact didn't take place in this
particular cave
uh
lead author so-and-so said he'd believe
the two groups must have exchanged
knowledge in some way well if they did
how come they didn't teach the
neanderthals the tool-making process you
would think that the neanderthals would
have loved to learn that i mean if they
were uh more or less human right if we
could have sex and viable sex with them
right
what precisely was the interaction we
just don't know we have no idea this is
the lead author okay so i want you to
understand that this guy could have done
a little bit of research instead of just
stating oh yeah they found a tooth that
belonged to a half breed or to a missing
link or whatever right
a research director said that the
discovery of just one modern human tooth
wasn't enough to definitely push back
the dates of the arrival of homo sapiens
in europe the dna might show evidence of
inner breeding between the two groups
the shape of the tooth and its internal
structure strongly suggested it belonged
to a modern human child even though the
tooth was damaged
okay so uh
was that a tooth of a child of a human
child was that child a half breed um you
know
did the neanderthals sleep with humans
in the same cave
did they have children but they didn't
exchange tools or to making
procedures
some questions arise right
and yeah this is this is the what these
people imagine uh i want to
want you to visualize it okay this is
neanderthals having sex with a female
human okay so this is how it went you
had the neanderthal you know a little
ape out there in the middle of nowhere
no clothes
and a girl just uh trying to get them to
uh
to mount her
is that how it went
is that what they imagined happened
okay
and the reason i i bring these images is
that we still don't know what a
neanderthal looked like but you know
since the beginning of this century you
know
i'm sorry since the beginning of the
20th century
you know neanderthals suffered the
greatest transition
uh evolution that you can imagine you
know they started being like that monkey
there if you look at them now today
they're all blonde and blue-eyed you
know all the girls would go after them
but i'm wondering if that girl would go
after that monkey he'd sleep with him
okay
and so here are my arguments for why
neanderthals and humans never had sex
never made it never had viable children
okay these are just the quick ones okay
just off the top of my head okay i
usually mention them and here they are
they're run down okay
fatal problems with admixture admixture
is the theory that says that here that
neanderthals disappeared because they
had sex with us essentially that's it
they were a smaller group like 10 of the
human population that's the argument and
because of that they kind of got
swallowed in our population okay but
what's the problem okay there's no
evidence of interbreeding that's the
first one we have no evidence whatsoever
of interbreeding what we do have is a
lot of opinions out there but no hard
evidence okay uh there's no
mitochondrial dna
we have
humans have no mitochondrial dna from
neanderthals meaning we had no
neanderthal mothers because
it's from the mother that we inherit
the neanderthal dna
the mitochondrial dna now uh we don't i
didn't put it up there again i didn't
put them all but we don't have any uh
uh
thing from the father's either okay the
y chromosome uh we don't we don't have
any from neanderthal fathers in other
words there's no human male alive today
that can trace his lineage to a
neanderthal
to a male neanderthal and none of us had
neanderthal mothers uh i think that
pretty much closes the argument that's
it okay sorry about it okay we have only
three percent approximate uh uh dna
um similar to
neanderthals and that could very well be
because we parted company maybe some
anywhere between 500 000 and eight
hundred thousand or maybe a million
years ago
uh you know these people the uh the
neanderthal descended from uh
homo erectus and they evolved in arctic
weather all by themselves without our
help and we came into europe you know 35
maybe 40 000 years ago and these guys
were there almost a million years ago
you know we have a
bipedal
animal
i don't know how many of those you'll
find uh in london near london okay eight
hundred thousand years ago in
happinessburg okay so you can look it up
and um you'll find several it's not like
one
they found several sites where some
um monkey-like creature lived in uh in
the near the london area i'll just say
it that way
and um and they and they hunted they
killed uh mammoths
i'm not sure
tigers can use tools to hunt mammoths
and they found the tools there as well
so
there was some animal almost a million
years ago in london
who can it be well it's got to be
homo erectus or maybe um
is it antecessor okay it's a little
different okay
and from then who came heidelberg's homo
heidelbergensis and from hyderabad who
came neanderthal lenses
that's it
and so there was this lineage we can
almost trace the entire lineage of the
neanderthals all the way to homo erectus
what does that have to do with humans
well humans apparently apparently
depending on the theory you espouse the
one that you embrace
uh apparently came from africa and we
moved up north maybe following the uh
you know the migrations of animals who
knows why we went up north but we went
up north and eventually entered europe
when we entered europe my my take on
that is that neanderthals were already
dying or dead one of the two
in other words humans when they entered
europe they entered uh empty crawls okay
so to speak they entered the caves and
they found the skeletons there that's it
maybe kick them outside and say i'm
going to live here now
it was like that i don't think humans
ever saw a neanderthal maybe 35 to 40
000 years ago when they entered europe
if they did uh
certainly they would not have raped them
or slept with them or anything like that
okay voluntary or you know consensual or
otherwise
it never happened
and then the other thing you know like i
showed there you know the dates don't
match
uh we don't have dates where we can put
a human together with a neanderthals and
some people say well how about in the
levant and the problem with the levant
is that
there's an argument about whether those
in the levant were neanderthals they are
distinctly they are distinct from the
neanderthals
in western europe like in spain france
and germany
the ones in the in israel and iraq are
different morphologically different than
the ones in europe okay so
whenever they talk about the levant
there's another argument out there and
i've got a couple papers out there on on
that subject that i've referenced
and uh
those people who analyze those bones say
these according to them these are not
neanderthals the ones that they have
there some other creature
you know that uh like the denisovans uh
in russia another creature that was
living there and it was not a
neanderthal okay so that's again it's a
little more complex than just saying oh
we have
the neanderthals in lebanon and they had
sex with uh humans no never happened
okay then um
uh you got to be aware that the dates
are fudged around by the paleontologists
they try to get their papers published
they want money
fame and so they print a lot of the
stuff
and the question is whether you're going
to believe it or not and yeah it's up to
everybody
uh to make sense of these things and
decide on their own okay i can't think
for you
uh humans were closed neanderthals did
not there's no uh needles found among
neanderthals okay no needles whatsoever
uh i don't think netherlands needed
clothing
and if you say well they did well then
how about the hydro birds did they also
wear clothes how about their parents uh
the
antecessors or the homo erectuses
did they need clothes as well i mean how
far are you gonna take it all the way to
lucy and say lucy needed clothes
no we did not invent
these this lineage did not invent
clothes ever the only animal ever that
ever invented clothes were humans
okay no other animal has invented
clothes not even neanderthals okay so
and they didn't need to because they
were in their own habitat they were born
in europe in arctic weather
you know they slept in the snow
just like a wolf sleeps in the snow so
this notion that people have that nano
fans had to wear and they used boots and
sandals and who knows
yeah so did the uh
mammoths you know have you ever seen a
mammoth with it you know with boots and
socks and you know
earmuffs
okay and then
[Music]
again we had maybe anywhere from 500 to
800 000 years separation so
even if we encountered the neanderthal
and we were you know so
[Music]
necessity of sleeping with that gorilla
i doubt very much we would have had
fertile offspring okay
and then half breeze we have found no
missing babies the only one the uh uh
what is it the
legervello
child in portugal that they found and uh
again um
again uh
it's it's interpretation some people say
that that's not a half breed it's a sick
child so who knows what it was and it
was buried purposely so it could have
been a sick child
maybe with arthritis who knows i mean
you know
that child is which is the closest one
we have out to a missing link is heavily
disputed
okay and then again was uh did was it
was rape involved or was this consensual
sex was it you know did they did the
fellas drink a beer and say let's swap
wives today is that is that how they did
it they all got into the cave and they
all had a big party
and uh the humans came in there and they
said let me hunt on your hunting grounds
as well while i'm at it i mean you got a
lot of game here enough for everybody
right
is that the way it was is that what
tribes do they all hunt together you
know
like uh what is it in papua new guinea
uh there's like
what 400 tribes they all hate each other
they can't stand each other they kill
each other
and these guys who are different species
you know like lions and tigers they're
gonna kiss and make up and sleep with
each other
yeah sure
okay uh then again you know no
the worst enemy of a human was another
human the worst enemy of a neanderthal
was another neanderthal
it's not like they were neighbors and
they all lived together they hated each
other the clans
hated each other they were enemies the
clan was the country
you had to have a passport to go to the
other side and you know even that
wouldn't help you
no visa for you
and so
you know
they they weren't friends and so someone
in your clan especially women
females right they would not venture too
far out from the clan from security
because there's no
it's got to be shouting distance it's
like help you know it's got to be like
that and they have to hear you because
they have to come in
and help you and it doesn't have to be
against another neanderthal or a human
or anything like that it could be
against a lion you know a lion comes
around and you say help you get up a
tree and maybe they can come in and
chase the lion away
so you can't go too far from the clan
it's not like you drift and say well i'm
gonna go to the city today you know and
have a party
it doesn't work that way not in the
jungle
or in the forest
okay and then the question is language
you know how do they uh say to the girls
i want to have sex with you and she
would understand right same language
so yeah i think there are too many
problems with this interbreeding
admixture theory
and
these are the issues that the
paleontologists do not attack they just
say look we found dna
in other words you have all these
geneticists right especially that got
into the business of paleontology and
what they do is they just count uh atoms
they count chromosomes they count you
know base pairs so they go in there and
they they do all these calculations and
they just give you a number and based on
those numbers they come up with
physical theories like of you know how
the neanderthal disappeared and since
they could never explain the extinction
of the neanderthals they finally went
with the geneticist and say oh we know
okay what is it that you know well what
we know is that the neanderthals had sex
with us and we know that because they're
still three percent left over from the
days that they were around
and so whether they disappeared well uh
the the they disappeared because you
know um
they were just a small group of people
of animals or humans
and uh and they we just kind of
swallowed them into our bigger
population and that's it
and now all they can tell you is what
diseases we inherited from them what
diseases we gave to them you know this
nonsense that has to do with covet and
stuff like that everybody loves that
stuff you know they're all looking at
their dna and you know how much the
neanderthal dna they have
uh i always say you know that all these
people have at least 50 dna and it all
comes from their mother
okay let's move on to the subject matter
today which is um
the other day i talked about dark matter
and uh from there i'm gonna look at
today is some of the groups around
the planet that are investigating dark
matter
this dark matter stuff uh
very important stuff because it's being
investigated heavily in many centers
and
they're using up a lot of resources in
other words money
they receive lots of money for these
investigations these researches
and what and so the question is where
are they now with all these research
have they advanced
uh an inch
a meter a mile how much have they uh
advanced in the uh search in the
understanding of dark matter
okay that's the question and is your
money well spent
and i just want to clarify for you that
dark matter has been around for i'd say
at least 40 years okay the ideas and so
on
uh they were probably there even before
them but for 40 years people have
investigating had been investigating
dark matter okay so let's find out where
these people stand let's find out how
much progress they have made
i hope a lot
okay so here we have uh
this is what i covered about a
i think a week or so ago okay and what
it is is essentially i'm saying that
dark matter is nothing but an equation
it's a number it's a fudge factor that
they had to put in there to understand
how a galaxy rotates or why it rotates
the way it does okay that's the issue
okay so here it is these are the
equations okay and you don't have to
look at all that i just want to point
out the one at the very bottom there
where you see v squared equal g m over
little r okay that's the one i'm going
to look at okay if you want to look at
all of this in more detail you got to go
a couple of videos back and you'll see
the original
discussion on this subject
okay so what do we have here well we
have that little v and we're going to
forget about the squared because that's
not important for the discussion today
that little v is velocity okay and what
is velocity we're talking about the
velocity of a star around
uh especially around the edge of a
galaxy okay and the way you calculate
that is you take the gravitational
constant g you take the big m which is
all the material
the mass okay of all the stars that are
within
the radius
of that star to the center of the galaxy
and the little r obviously is the radius
which is really the distance between the
center of the galaxy and where the star
is okay so that's what that equation
state tells you
if you increase the radius you can see
that the galaxy on the bottom has the
star is farther out okay so the one on
the top
has a shorter radius the one on the
bottom has a longer radius okay so the
radius is bigger that means the little r
on the equation is going to get bigger
if you increase the denominator if you
increase that little r the v
goes down the velocity should come down
but that's not the case the case is that
when you increase the r what they
observe is that the v goes up as well
and they say how can that possibly be
that's impossible because you know if if
it's farther out it should go slower not
faster why does the velocity increase
when the radius increases that's the
issue that's what they had to explain so
what did they do they went in there they
said okay when i increase the r
uh the velocity is greater and so what
they did they created this factor known
as dark matter they created a fudge
factor to account for the velocity of a
star that is farther out from the center
of a galaxy okay so this was the issue
this is how they fixed it who fixed it
physicists absolutely not it was fixed
by mathematicians this is completely a
mathematical solution nothing but so
what is dark matter dark matter is
nothing but a fudge factor in an
equation
that's how it starts
now they told everybody every astronomer
out there and also the people at the the
particle uh people the folks who
accelerate particles at the accelerators
uh they said go look for it
and uh so you know what does it look
like well it's kind of dark
and uh weighs a lot
and so let's look at this let's find out
because if it's dark
this is very simple okay very simple
if dark matter is dark and it's around
the edge of a galaxy because that's
where they have to put it in order to
account for the behavior of the galaxy
the way it rotates with the stars on the
outside going faster than the ones on
the inside then they have to sprinkle
all this stuff around the galaxy that's
where they have to put it okay and so
all this uh
dark matter
it forms like a halo
around the galaxy okay
it's got to be there in order for the
galaxy to rotate as it rotates as they
see it rotating it today and to explain
why a star at the edge travels faster
than the ones on the inside that's the
argument okay
okay so what did they have to explain
here it is here's the graph
this is mathematics but it gives you an
idea because it's superimposed upon
a galaxy and the stars on a galaxy and
what you're going to see here is that
the farther a star is from the center
the faster it goes which is very
counter-intuitive
right and here it is you can see what
they expected that's the one expected
from visible disk
the as you go farther out the distance
the speed
should go lower okay so the more
distance the speed should come down
that's not the case what observations
show is that as you go farther out the
star goes faster
how did they fix the problem oh very
simple they fixed all these problems
very simple and what they did they
sprinkled all these kilograms on the
outside okay so now you have all these
kilograms
very heavy kilograms by the way and by
doing so they fixed the problem they
were able to imitate what they observed
in the night sky okay so this was the
issue this is how dark matter came into
being sometime back
and that's where we are today so again
they told all the astronomers go look
for it they told the particle physicist
go look for it now that's what they're
all doing they're spending your money
looking for it
we wish them good luck obviously right
okay so here we have um the halo and
again this halo's on the outside of the
galaxy okay keep that in mind
but you can imagine
um
how can i explain this
you have all this dark matter on the
outside right
it's heavy
they say it's dark we can't see it very
well because it's the night sky and
there's no contrast there
okay so what's the problem if this
halo which extends far beyond the edges
of the visible part of the galaxy right
extends way beyond that
if that halo is there
if a star goes behind
this halo
you should be able to see right through
the hail i'm sorry you should be able to
see that star through the halo because
the halo is there in its way if it's
dark matter
okay and uh so here it is this is what
the halo looks like okay this is the
drawing by the way this is not real okay
it's a drawing it's an imitation of what
the halo
they think looks like okay here it is
sorry i gave you the wrong one it should
be the other one i think it's this one
yeah this is what it should look like
okay halo
but the one i showed you just now which
is this one this is what it does look
like
in other words you can see right through
the halo and see the stars at the edge
of that galaxy stars are in the
background in other words so we don't
see this which is what they
explain what they describe they say look
there's a halo around the galaxy okay
fine why can't we see through the
what what can we see through the halo
why is it that the halo doesn't block
out the stars that are behind in the
region of the halo that's the question
and this is what we see
and this is what they uh
explain or what they describe okay
that's that's where the problem arises
okay so we can't see through the halo
and so the question is uh whether maybe
we're looking for angels and ghosts out
there
you know casper is that what we're
trying to see
okay so uh this is the issue the issue
is that
these people are saying you know there's
a halo there it's dark matter fine great
if it's dark matter it should block out
any star or any galaxy that falls within
that behind the halo you shouldn't be
able to see through the halo because
it's dark matter
maybe they should call it transparent
matter or translucent matter because we
can see right through that so-called
halo
so what is this invisible matter are
they looking for ghosts
you know i mean they're doing a lot of
equations in their offices
and the question is how does that match
what we see out there
and they're saying well here's the
equation that explains why stars on the
outside of in the galaxy travel faster
yeah that's great
that's maybe one solution maybe there's
another solution
and what they say what else could it be
it's got to be some kind of dark matter
there
well if that's dark matter why can why
can we see right through that dark
matter maybe it's not dark matter maybe
it's translucent or transparent matter
maybe we got the wrong name for this
dark matter thingy okay
okay so um
here are the numbers
this is where your money's going
so pay attention they're stealing from
your bank okay and i want you to see
that okay here we have the department of
energy of the united states and this is
just the year 2020 they do this every
year but in 2020 they spent 132 dollars
132 million dollars right for high
energy physics research okay what does
that mean what is high energy physics
research well there at the bottom you
see it higgs boson
higgs bosons right neutrinos dark matter
dark energy and uh search for new
physics that's what all that money's
going to and it went to 64 universities
who you know
people apply for these funds and they
say i'm going to be doing research on
black dark matter oh okay and i need ten
thousand dollars and so they the guy
justifies it they give him ten thousand
bucks and then they move on to another
university and do the same thing
so they spent 132 million dollars 64
universities that's like uh what is it
uh 20
uh million per university on the average
more or less okay
and this is
what where your money's going okay and
let's find out what are the results of
this i mean this was 2020. they've been
doing this at least for 40 years
okay so what are the results of all this
stuff well here's nasa okay i mean nasa
receives a lot of uh the inputs from
universities and so on they have
they also fund a lot of these
universities as well especially for
these types of projects and here's nasa
okay dark energy dark matter this is
from their site this is from nasa site
and says we are much more certain that
what dark matter is not
than we are of what it is
this is after 40 years folks okay we
know what it's not not what it is
first it is dark well if it's dark why
can we see the stars and why can we see
the stars in the background behind the
halo if it's dark maybe they should have
said it's invisible or it's uh
translucent or transparent
meaning that it is not in the form of
stars and planets that we see okay
observations show that there is far too
little visible matter in the universe to
make up the 27 percent required for the
observations because they say that 20
that dark matter constitutes 27
of the matter in the universe okay and
they say the visible stars the visible
stuff doesn't account for that weight
that they need to make the equations
come out right that's what they're
saying there
second it is not in the form of dark
clouds or normal matter matter made up
of particles called baryons we know this
because we would be able to detect
baryonic clouds by their absorption of
radiation passing through them okay and
how come they don't uh check the
radiation passing through the halo
okay
third dark matter is not anti-matter
because uh we do not see the unique
gamma rays that are produced when
antimatter annihilates with matter great
finally we can rule out large galaxy
sized black holes on the basis of how
many gravitational lenses we see in
other words light is not bent around
the dark matter okay so that's what
they're saying
so they can't put a black hole in that
same region high concentrations of
matter bend light passing near them from
objects further away but we do not see
enough lensing event to suggest that
such an object to make up required 25
dark matter contribution
so uh it doesn't do that lensing thingy
you know that einstein invented you know
the einstein
uh lensing that the star
or the black hole and because it's a
collapsed star you know a bunch of mass
there invisible mass supposedly bends
light but they don't have that same
situation with the dark matter you don't
see light bending around a galaxy
and so they can't say well there's a
black hole there that we can't see
either no they can't do that so they had
to invent dark matter they invented a
new variable
lots of mass
conveniently dark better yet invisible
in intangible in
uh what you can't you can see through it
it's translucent transparent
you you figure it out okay
okay here's cern you know the this is
the one here in switzerland okay they do
accelerations
and they're in the dark matter business
as well and these are their numbers
these are the countries that put money
to keep certain running by the way the
united states uh also puts money into
this okay but uh it doesn't show up here
because this is like their regular
budget but the united states has donated
quite a bit of money to cern as well and
you can see there it's uh quite a bit of
money okay we're talking in the billions
okay not in the millions but in the
billions
and this is their budget okay or at
least this is the money that's coming
into cern what percentage of this goes
to dark matter i don't know but right
now there's a lot of research going into
dark matter okay so uh this is something
you gotta
consider for any uh
understanding of this dark matter thingy
okay
okay uh and so
here's that's the money
what has cern produced with all this
money well let's find out here's uh what
cern has produced over the years okay so
very important find out if your money if
if you got your money's worth okay here
it is dark matter this directly from
cern invisible dark matter makes up most
of the universe but we can only detect
it from its gravitational effects
well are you sure it's a gravitational
effect could it be an electromagnetic
effect maybe
okay i mean i'm just suggesting right
okay
not trying to shove gravity down your
throat like you are trying to do with me
okay
galaxies in our universe seem to be
achieving an impossible feat no kidding
under gravity it should be an impossible
feat they are rotating with such speed
that the gravity generated by their
observable matter could not possibly
hold them together
okay yeah if you want to hold something
together you need some kind of elongated
thing that holds the stars together
between them you need
uh interconnectivity
that's what you need then you can talk
about why they're together why a star
doesn't fly out or is flung out of the
uh
galaxy
they should have torn themselves apart
long ago absolutely if you're talking
about discrete particles there's no
reason for any uh galaxy to remain
in in a single piece
the same is true of galaxies in clusters
which leads uh scientists to believe
that something we cannot see is at work
that i don't doubt you know it's
something you cannot see for those of
you who insist on see and touch well
there you see they can't see the stuff
they think something we have yet to
detect directly is giving these galaxies
extra mass generating the extra gravity
they need to stay intact well it's not
gravity it's what it is is that all uh
all atoms are interconnected then then
it's very easy and yeah you can't see it
so don't don't look for it with your
telescope please
this strange and unknown matter was
called dark matter since it is not
visible well yeah but again if uh you
can't see through the um
i mean if you can see through the stars
right through the halo
then maybe the word dark is wrong maybe
it's invisible translucent transparent
those are better words for that type of
matter okay and yeah it's conveniently
uh heavy and conveniently dark so you
can't see a contrast between space empty
space which according to relativity is a
physical object also but that's a
secondary issue but there's no contrast
between the dark matter and space black
space dark space okay
transparent space translucent space
okay here's the australian research
center okay another uh group that
heavily investigates uh you know this
dark matter thingy
and it's the australian research council
you can tell there by the jumping
kangaroo
dark matter explained they're going to
explain to us dark matter so finally i
guess our money is finally
invested property because we're going to
get an explanation says dark matter it
is a mysterious substance that holds
galaxies together and contributes 84 of
the matter of the universe its existence
is inferred
from its gravitational interaction and
the
exploration of the nature of dark matter
is considered science's next frontier
and let's see what it is it says the
existence of that matter has established
has been established by many
astrophysical and cosmological
observations they say that you can't see
it but they they established it through
observation
so what is it that they observed maybe
they observed visible matter and not the
translucent dark matter
since dark matter cannot be seen
directly there is you know they tell you
they talk about observations they say
they can't see it directly its presence
is inferred and they call that an
observation because they infer from its
gravitational influence on other objects
okay well maybe it's not that uh maybe
we have to figure out what gravity
gravity is maybe it's interconnectivity
maybe all the atoms maybe all the stars
maybe all the universe is interconnected
all the matter in the universe then we
could find out you know how you do
action at a distance but yeah if you
just talk about numbers and say mass
does this and gravity does that
well yeah then in force and so on and
well yeah then you're talking about
concepts and you cannot explain a
physical mechanism with concepts
however the identity of the particles
that make up this dark matter is unknown
no kidding well you know i mean what are
they if they're particles we're done
just talk about grains of sand right and
what each grain of sand is weighs a
million tons
and that's what you're going to sprinkle
out there and then again how do you
explain with that assuming that's the
case right how do you explain with
putting grains of sand that weight tons
and are invisible right translucent dark
whatever
how do you explain that one
star does not fly out of that system
what holds it there mass
does it is it gravity the concept
gravity is that what holds it there
no you got to have some physical
mechanism that's what these people never
were able to
first make an assumption of and then to
explain you know they don't have a
mechanism to find out what dark matter
is well all you have to do is just tell
me
to tell me what it is we need to propose
new theories of what dark matter could
be and test those ideas
so how are they going to test ideas i
mean uh you got to make an assumption
that's what you need to do and you don't
test assumptions what you do is you make
an assumption so that you can explain
your theory of what keeps a galaxy you
know uh
compressed you know it doesn't fly apart
in pieces that's all you need to do
and so what is it they're saying they
don't know what dark matter is but
they're going to find out
well i mean you've already decided that
dark matter is a bunch of heavy
particles that are invisible dark
translucent
whatever
you've already decided that so we know
what dark matter is it's a bunch of
particles and we know that also because
all these centers like cern and slack
and fermilab they're all looking for it
in their accelerators what are you
accelerating what do you expect to find
well you expect to find particles so we
know what dark matter is according to
your mentality it's particles that are
very heavy and they're dark
okay that's it we know what it is
so what is it these people have been
doing for 40 years trying to explain
dark matter and that they don't know
what it is and just gobbling up money
investigating something that they're
still looking for because they don't
know what it is it's just a circular
argument i mean what are these people up
to
okay here's the cambridge uh cavalier
institute another
famous um
you know important uh doc research
center alcohol dark research center i
like that
and it says despite abundant evidence of
the presence of dark matter in the
universe the direct searches in
laboratories have found no viable
candidate that would explain the dark
matter
yeah no kid okay i like if you said
nature of dark matter that's the title
of this
it is thus increasingly important to
explore astrophysical and cosmological
probes of the nature of dark matter yeah
no kidding especially with my money
right currently the most stringent
constraints
on the nature of dark matter candidates
come from studies of the clustering of
the intergalactic medium in spectra of
distant quasars remember what they're
saying is uh they're looking for stuff
that's between the galaxies that's what
they want to that's where they focus
uh maybe their telescopes or whatever to
see if they can see something there
between the galaxies because they're few
and far apart in comparison to like
stars or planets okay the distribution
of gas and stars are a potential
observable
feature that could help
unravel the nature of dark matter
so what do they have well they have uh
the astronomers looking at the skies
with their telescopes and they have the
uh particle
uh
mathematicians accelerating particles
trying to smash them to see if they can
produce dark matter in their cauldrons
and and you're
and you're
funding all this effort
and they don't know what it is after 40
years
when they already know what it is
because they're saying it's particles
they're heavy
they're translucent or whatever the dark
so they know what it is
so just tell me what it is tell me that
they're particles that they're heavy
they're round maybe they're square i
don't know cubic
and i guess they're 3d right they weigh
a lot and uh
dark maybe translucent transparent we're
done we know what it is
what do you mean you don't know what it
is if you already decided what it is
because that's what you need to put
weight sufficient weight mass in your
equation for the equation to come out
right in other words meaning that the
equation now matches what you observe
a visible matter meaning the stars don't
run out of the galaxy and the stars on
the outside travel faster than the ones
on the inside
okay
so this is the issue okay and here in
frankfurt hey we don't stay behind you
think uh we're dumb here or what we have
here sabine
uh sabine
hassemfelder and she works at the
frankfurt institute of advanced studies
in fact close to my home here in
frankfurt and uh
she's known as a oh her title is a
theoretical physicist i don't know what
a theoretical physicist is either you're
a physicist or you're a stamp collector
no such thing as a theoretical physicist
we're all theorists that's what a
physicist is the theorist
whose research focuses on the
phenomenology of quantum gravity
whatever that is what they're trying to
do is merge again
relativity with with quantum mechanics
and that's what quantum gravity is it's
a euphemism for that i guess
uh figure of speech and here's the key
one and super fluid dark matter
what the hell is super fluid dark matter
well it's whenever you see super fluid
okay uh there's no friction
that's the point and usually you get
that at very low temperatures okay so
that's why they use that word superfluid
that adjective there whenever you see
superfluid or super whatever they're
talking about frictionless uh
matter
meaning usually uh at very low
temperatures okay that's what uh
you know the super computers are also
all about okay she studies the role of
lawrence variance and locality which
would be altered in the discovery of
quantum gravity a topic that she has
been trying to find experimental
evidence for
she is the author of lost in math how
beauty leads physics astray
and i think that's a good uh way of
putting it i think this lady
you have that situation there beauty
leads physics astray
and uh that would mean that she also
thinks she's uh beautiful okay i guess
that's what she's implying with that
beauty leaves
physics astray
love that title
okay and so what does sabine talk about
okay and this is what she's proposing
okay this is a summary of what she's
proposing super fluid dark matter plus
modified newtonian dynamics
which was
created or invented by this fellow
jewish fellow
what is it mordecai mordechai milgram
and uh she says recent studies have
shown recent studies meaning her okay by
the way
uh that dark matter with a super fluid
phase in which phonons remember we
covered phonons what are phonons a bunch
of vibrating particles
that vibrate somehow in unison okay
that's called a phonon it's a particle
of sound
so
particle vibration okay mediate a long
distance force gives rise to the
phenomenologically well-established
regularities of modified newtonian
dynamics mon which is again it's a
modified
newtonian
equation that milgram came up with
superfluid dark matter therefore has
emerged as a promising explanation for
astrophysical observations by combining
the benefits of both particle dark
matter and mond meaning the you know
modified newtonian dynamics or its
relativistic completions respectively
our analysis demonstrates that super
fluid dark matter fits the data well
with parameters in reasonable ranges
okay so she's got this duality
she's introducing on the one hand a
modified equation for gravity she's
saying that gravity out there at the
galactic level does not behave like
gravity here on earth that's the first
one that's what mon says okay and in
parallel to that she's introducing this
super fluidity which means that there is
a frictionless matter that's essentially
it okay
does she know what dark matter is i'm
sure if you ask her and she's been
studying dark matter for at least 20
years i would say she wouldn't be able
to tell you and here i'm telling you
what dark matter is please listen to me
i'm telling you what dark matter is it's
particles that weigh a lot and are
invisible
see how simple it was that's what dark
matter is and i don't know what they're
trying to do what are they they're
trying to find it out there they can't
see it so why are they putting their
telescopes between galaxies to see if
they can see it if they are already
telling you
that it's invisible it's dark it's
translucent whatever weighs a lot it's
particles
it's a bunch of sand that weighs tons of
you know kilograms
okay so we're done i mean we know what
dark matter is
so so i i have an analogy for you okay
and it's known as the schrodinger's
black cat analogy it's a schrodinger
black cat and the klingon okay
and this is i think the perfect analogy
which for what you're seeing with dark
matter okay if you bear with me i'll
i'll carry you through the fable okay
this is a fable okay
and so here's uh irwin schroedinger he
encounters a uh a klingon okay klingon
comes from outer space
and schrodinger is going to talk to him
about his black cat which apparently he
lost okay so
so here he's going to try to explain to
the klingon okay that about this cat he
says to the klingon he says i'm looking
for a cat
can you help me find it
and so the klingon says what's a cat
okay and so schrodinger goes in there
and says well i don't know
i have no clue
and so the klingon says well what's it
look like can you can you at least tell
me what it looks like say well all i
know is that it's black
well okay not much to go on so the
klingon said well uh
where did you lose it
and he says i lost the cat in a dark
room one night
uh-huh
and he said well where's the room
located
and schrodinger says well look it's uh
it's on the other side of town some 15
miles away from here
and so the klingon says well i'm not
supposed to find it i mean how am i
supposed to help you find this this cat
that you're talking about that you don't
know what it is which is apparently
black the only thing you can tell me
about them and you lost them 100 miles
away you know and uh i'm not supposed to
find it and so
the schrodinger says well here's a
microscope that you can use to look for
it
and that's essentially uh what the story
of dark matter is all about okay that's
in a nutshell
dark matter for you
okay
anyways what we're going to do now we're
going to do some questions that people
ask some comments that people made
and let's go with those
here here we have the first one he says
can you explain quantum levitation
okay um
what i want to do really is i'm not
going to explain quantum levitation we
can very easily no problem there but i
want to
focus on something else that is inferred
or implied by this
questionnaire here this uh thought who's
asking
um and that is that
people think that quantum
has an explanation for this so-called
quantum levitation effect
and so they they kind of want to
challenge they say well look we have an
answer do you have an answer that's more
or less i guess the way i interpret his
question so let's so i just want to
point out to one thing i want to harp on
one issue alone and that is that quantum
mechanics has no explanation whatsoever
for quantum levitation okay
so here's a fellow out there who uh
explained it in in quite a bit of detail
and i just pulled the main points from
his
exposition right
and this is what the cell says electrons
will swirl around indefinitely in
superconductors
again why does that mean why why is that
well because again there's no friction
remember you have anytime you have super
super fluidity super conductors what
they're talking super computers they're
all talking about no friction
essentially that's the bottom line okay
so they're saying these electrons for
some reason uh can swivel around
indefinitely because they slide around
and there's nothing to stop them there's
there's no friction
no internal resistance to uh in the
medium okay electrons in superconductors
act like
there is a mysterious force connecting
them this is what this guy says well i
guess there's talking about what i see
when i show you at the bottom there you
know yeah the electrons are connected
the electron shells are connected
they're connected by a rope
okay
that's now we have an answer to his
question or to this uh
predicament
and when you move superconductor towards
a magnet it exposes it to a changing
magnetic field which induces a voltage
and that voltage pushes electrons around
okay so he's going to move that magnetic
field it's going to induce a voltage and
the voltage what is the voltage a
difference in potential right and so
that's going to move or compel the
electrons to move around great okay so
now we have magnetic field lines of a
magnet do not go through the
superconductor like they do through an
ordinary magnet or a piece of metal
the guy just states that he doesn't
explain why that's the case okay he says
they just go through
and they don't go through like they go
through a magnet meaning that they slide
through without again distortion or any
kind of friction
okay so the file continues he says type
2 semiconductors allow some field inside
superconductors
yeah i mean what's a field what is it is
this a marijuana field what kind of
field are we talking about football
field
what is a field there's no such thing as
a field
and so he says it creates a magnetic
vortex
okay so this is essentially what this
fellow uh explained if you can call that
an explanation okay
and so they get away with this and
people say oh okay uh that's over my
head but i guess the guy explained it
no when you analyze what the guy said he
never explained anything he didn't
explain squat that's the reality of it
okay what the guy did was just mention
some words throw some fancy words around
saying oh this is a magnetic field we
have a superconductor over there and
what have we learned have we learned a
mechanism of what's happening inside the
so-called superconductor why
because we have ultra cold
uh environment
uh there's no friction have we
understood that
what it does to a magnetic field
the guy says well the there's a
difference in potential voltage that
moves electrons around and because
there's no friction
uh then we have this magnetic field
we haven't understood the x we we don't
understand the mechanism
okay that's the point
and so yeah um
here's uh what he illustrates okay he
just states this okay he puts it on his
video gets a hundred thousand hits right
and what does he say well if you send
the magnetic field through uh metal it
goes right through it whereas when you
go through a superconductor it goes down
the edges on the outside
and that there is a way of sending it
right through the center as well and
that's when they manipulate this stuff
and but again you don't know what a
magnetic field is what are those lines
just tell me what the lines are
and they they never say that they just
say well here's the magnetic field
meaning that the bunch of lines
and so no they don't have an explanation
for quantum uh for this quantum effect
okay levitation
because they can float a magnet or
something on top of one of these
superconductors
that's all they can do they can play
around with it and say this is what we
observe oh this is nice this is neat you
know i can float something and i can't
see what keep what's keeping it up
and and so they don't have an
explanation for that and so you know i
don't need to explain that either i'll
explain it when quantum mechanics
explains it okay yes we do have an
explanation but there's no need to put
ours you know no need to fight if the
other guy's not fighting on his side i
need an explanation when quantum comes
up with an explanation i'll be glad to
offer an explanation in exchange
that debunks the nonsense of quantum
mechanics meaning discrete particles
they will not be able to explain uh
either superconductivity or or
levitation uh with particles because
again why would something float over a
bunch of
over a sandbox that's essentially what
these people are explaining i mean you
have a sandbox all particles all
discrete particles
why would anything float above the
sandbox
that's what you gotta explain when you
explain that i'll be glad to give you my
version of quantum levitation
okay so here's another
fella who
brings up an issue
and again a lot of this has to do with
these concepts known as like in this
case the ether
fella says dark matter is the um counter
spatial i guess he got that from wheeler
uh poor old kenny wheeler he he talks
about the counter spatial right
and fluid which some might uh call an
ether
ether yeah see they're all synonyms the
counter spatial the counter space uh the
ether
all of these are synonyms according to
these people and so the okay so the file
says everything is pressure
see
all these people have always
been able to explain pressure they said
but they haven't even been able to
explain that but let's assume they say
with particles you can press you can
compress something okay like if you have
a put something in a sandbox all those
sand
pieces or grains are pushing against
whatever you put in there we we all
understand that if they're in direct
contact right
great
explain pull now with your sandbox
that's what you got to explain
so the particle hypothesis dies with the
word pull
you cannot explain action at a distance
pull
with particles with extreme particles
that's where the ether dies okay the
ether bunch of particles and that's
another issue that
we have also with the etherist they
never tell you what the ether is they
always tell you what the ether ain't
they say you're wrong bill that's not
the ether not a bunch of particles okay
what is it and they run away they never
tell you what the ether is
and if they define it obviously it's a
concept so they had better not define it
i need a picture
i need if you're going to use it as a an
object i need a picture of ether that's
what we need so point to somewhere on
the internet where they have a picture
of the ether or make one your own and
upload it that way we can see
what the ether is
what it is okay that's the only way
we're going to understand the ether now
if you think ether is a concept then you
can't use it as a battering ram you
can't say the ether move the particle or
the ether waves you can't say that
you can't use the ether for anything if
it's a concept
and if it's an object
we need an image
show us a picture of the ether
that's it we're done
so easy
another vowel brings up the ether lots
of ether is we have moonies we have flat
earth and we have etheris here's another
ethers okay and he says
uh if all atoms are connected with ropes
okay meaning my model right
we would still end with a dense
structure of space whatever it may be
called
fabric of space
or ether
again these people don't understand the
difference of what i'm proposing they
think that ether which is just a bunch
of particles right
is the same thing as what i'm showing
there at the bottom which is
interconnected atoms
no that's not an ether
either something else ether is a bunch
of loose particles disconnected
particles discrete particles we are
proposing not an ether we're saying that
all atoms are physically interconnected
those two notions those two starting
points are not the same
under any circumstance okay so
if you can't understand that well i
don't know how to help you but anyways
here we have um mr robert uh laughlin
and he's a nobel prize and this is what
he said about the ether okay here you
have it okay he said modern concept of
the vacuum of space confirmed every day
by experiment is a relativistic ether
but we don't call it this because it is
taboo
nobel prize okay and so what is he
saying he's saying uh we use the ether
also but we don't call it the ether
because otherwise people would say what
do you mean ether i thought the ether
died at the end of the 19th century
and here all these people are using the
ether they just call it what
the false vacuum uh
space time i mean what is space time
space time is defined
and this is by mr hawking not by me okay
so it's defined as a bunch of points
and what's the point it's an event
what's an event is a point in space time
and so you have all these points meaning
particles
meaning
discrete particles that are disconnected
one with each other
and they build space time with that a
four dimensional object that you cannot
imagine
that's the famous ether of relativity
what did einstein say
that uh general relativity
you know space time without the ether is
unthinkable
so does
the general relativity has it gotten rid
of the ether
absolutely not
okay
okay another fellow
talks about what science is good subject
okay what is science and he says
descriptions tells us
what is there explanation is why it is
there
and well no uh description tells us what
is there but
explanation is not why it is there
explanation is has to do with causes and
mechanisms that's not why it is there
okay
and then he says science explains and
rattles on something else but yeah you
gotta take that up with uh donald
simenek he's a emeritus professor loch
haven university and he says science
does not explain
science describes why why did mr uh
cement say that well he said that
because mathematics only describes an
equation is only a description that's
all that mathematics does and so the
mathematicians have converted science
into or made it
equated it with mathematics and they say
look science is mathematics anything
outside of that is not science
and what does mathematics do describe so
they say science only describes it
doesn't explain why because they cannot
explain
especially not with particles and
certainly not with equations
okay so that's the situation with with
that
okay um
here's a foul looks up he puts the
definitions of definit of uh description
and explanation he got him from the
oxford dictionary and it says describe
give an account in words of someone or
something including all the relevant
characteristics qualities or events but
then when he goes to explain he says
and again this comes from the dictionary
again no one has defined these terms in
10 000 years
make an idea situation or problem clear
to someone by what describing
so
according to
official dumb okay
uh an explanation is just a description
that's that's the way they see it
and why because the mathematicians have
taken over science okay they call the
shots they have the money they have the
power and that's the only reason that
science is equated to mathematics
and that's all that mathematics can do
okay another fellow
gives a better
notion and i like this one okay he says
an explanation should determine the
cause
listen to this okay
paradoxically as soon as an adequate
explanation arrives it becomes an effect
and therefore a description
i like that that was good
requiring further explanation in other
words he's saying
the cause is the explanation the effect
is the description
okay
i like that i i you learn from some of
some of these people
they're not all like these other fellows
okay that was good anyways i should
incorporate that as well i'm gonna steal
it from him i'll give him credit but uh
i like that okay
uh yeah i think the effect it's a good
way of putting it saying that the cause
is the explanation and the effect is the
description that's good and obviously
that means that description and
explanation are not the same okay
okay another fellow
brings up another subject and he says if
i can get it up here i don't understand
gravity with the ropes
okay you say it's not pull absolutely
it's not pull the ropes do not pull
there is tension be on the rope between
any two atoms in the universe so anytime
you look at a system of two atoms all
you have is tension there's no point one
po one atom is not pulling another atom
okay
okay uh
just stand out giving the impression of
greater weight well i don't think he
understood that uh
it's not the impression of greater
weight i don't know what he understood
there but obviously he's not
understanding the theory okay why do
things fall or orbit okay doesn't the
pen you drop have to be pulled to the
ground well the first one we have to
explain is orbit okay so let's uh let me
show you him this first okay here's
orbit okay
and
for orbit you don't need to pull really
all you need is tension let's assume
this
it's really a little elastic okay but
let's say it's to maximum okay so you
can't pull it no more
okay so you know if you roll it around
that explains
uh gravity gravity means that there's
tension
and you have centripetal motion and
centripetal centrifugal motion
centrifugal motion towards the sun
meaning meaning my hand and this is the
earth and so it's it's got these this
centrifugal versus centripetal okay
that's what it is okay and that's why
the uh ropes are tight
okay if something would happen then the
earth would gradually fall towards the
sun not because
the roast become loose
they're always under tension because
every atom in the universe is tugging
so to speak there's tension between all
of them in the universe
and so we're we're under tension here
because on the other side of the
universe there's uh other atoms which
are also you know they have as much
right as we do to
to be
pulled to use that word to be under
tension
that you have to have the same velocity
of light which is the uh a measure of
the tension on the rope okay
anyways but here's the um
that was the
uh gravity part
now let's look at uh the
of um
of why something falls to the floor in
other words one is why that was the
orbit part that's what i meant to say
that was the orbit why something orbis
because it's twirled around very simple
gravity here's gravity okay uh
in a nutshell okay
all atoms are of an object are
physically connected to atoms of another
object as they come closer together the
ropes fan out is it because the object
is pulling at it absolutely not what
happens is when the astronaut falls it
he drifts and as he drifts it's the
other way around don't ask what's
pulling on him ask him
he's drifting towards the earth and
because he drifts the
ropes are fanning out
ever more as you can see there on the
bottom two objects which are far apart
all the ropes come together as a single
coaxial there's no pull it's just
tension and as one object that blow
approaches another there's still tension
on each rope tension doesn't change it's
always the velocity of light which
dictates the tension on the rope but as
they get closer together the ropes fan
out and because they fan out the object
at different locations has different
weight with respect to the first object
that's what it is okay that's all that
gravity is under the rope model okay
we don't ask you to believe it we ask
you to understand it yeah that's
important people think oh you didn't
convince me i don't care if i did i just
want you to understand if you understood
it i achieved my goal okay and here it
is in uh fast motion i guess you could
say here's the elephant with his
uh suit space suit that people say you
can't live in space well here you have
the elephant he lives in space as he
falls to earth okay the ropes fan out
that's all it is that's how simple
gravity is when your spoon falls to the
floor all the ropes connecting every
atom of your spoon to every atom on
earth fan out that's all gravity is
under the rope model
very simple
and the last one got i like this one
this one made me laugh
and uh i hope
you see the the
amusement in it as well okay here it is
phil says dussin is almost 5 billion
years old and is traveling 500 000 miles
per hour as it orbits the milky way okay
i guess you measure that this roughly
comes out to one mile per hour increase
in velocity every 10 000 years okay
the milky way galaxy is 13.7 billion
years old and is traveling at 1.37
million miles per hour towards the great
attractor
and the guy did a million calculations
and he says i wrote him a and published
a series of six books on this and more
last year
and the interesting part here is that he
uses he says that the milky way galaxy
is 13.7 billion years old he got that
from general relativity you know and it
turns out that when you look at the
history proposed by relativity this is
from them this is not from me by the way
okay and they say that
galaxies came into being only 700
million years ago
so he did all these calculations he
wrote six books he published them and he
used the wrong value because he's using
a value that's got to do
what it has to do with is that he
saw this in reverse he thought the
galaxies are 13 billion years old when
it's the other way around the galaxies
came into existence
13.7 billion years after the big bang
and they're only now around 700 million
years old if you are to believe in the
assumptions of quantum
general relativity so that was so funny
that he came up with all this stuff and
just in case here's a proof evidence
okay a different way of visualizing this
you see that the galaxies came into
existence only 700 million years ago
according to the current model of
general relativity okay
so uh what is so sad is this poor fellow
he went out there this did all this work
all this calculations wrote six books
published them
and he's got the wrong numbers
okay folks i'll see you next time i
think it's on wednesday we'll see you
then